what is going on everybody welcome back
to the cosmic wonder I'm Warren Thompson
thanks for stopping by today and a lot
of people have been hitting me up asking
me about Tom Holland quitting acting now
just to clarify right off the bat he's
not permanently quitting acting in fact
it does seem like he's already signed a
new deal with Sony and Marvel Studios to
return as Peter Parker as Spider-Man and
the Marvel Cinematic Universe and could
quite possibly be jumping over to the
Sony spiderverse as well appearing in
both universes and actually possibly
fighting again with Toby Maguire
Spider-Man and Andrew Garfield
Spider-Man in both universes as well but
I know a lot of people are freaking out
about Tom Holland saying he has taken a
Hiatus from acting but we're gonna break
down everything you need to know about
what Tom Holland has said about his
acting Hiatus and when we can expect
Spider-Man 4 to come out we have a
release date window it seems also talk
about his role with the new Avengers
team and how he could possibly be going
over to the Sony spiderverse as well so
if you'd like to stay up to date on
Spider-Man and Marvel and General be
sure to subscribe to the channel also
we're doing a giveaway we'll talk about
that at the end of the vid so Tom
Holland has recently announced in an
interview with extra that he is taking
only a year off of acting and quite
honestly this probably won't really
affect Spider-Man 4 but we'll get into
that in just a second because the reason
that he has taken off acting is actually
quite important for him and that is he
has taken a year off to essentially
focus on his mental health and of course
his physical health as well this is
coming after he just got done with the
crowded room because not only did he act
in it but he also produced it as well
and he literally said that the show
broke him he said and I quote I'm no
stranger to hard work I've lived by the
idea that hard work is good work then
again the show did break me there did
come a time where I needed a break and
disappeared and went to Mexico for a
week and had time on a beach and laid
low I'm now taking a year off that is a
result of how difficult the show was I
am excited to see how it turns out I
feel like our hard work wasn't in vain
so a couple key points here one and this
should be the priority of this news is
that Tom Holland is taking a break so he
can be okay himself he has done a ton of
work since he has debuted a Spider-Man
and Captain America Civil War he's
become extremely popular not just for
Marvel movies but other movies as well
taking on franchises like Uncharted and
then doing the crowded room which he
said literally broke him so first things
first Tom Holland needs to do this
because he needs to keep his mental
health healthy and he needs to keep his
body physically healthy as well so this
is a really good thing the second
important thing is that he literally
says I'm taking a year off that's it
just a year he doesn't say I'm quitting
acting indefinitely Or I'm quitting
acting for a while he literally States
hey I'm gonna take a year off and this
is actually most likely due to
Spider-Man 4 beginning to film around
that time in about a year based off of
what we've heard about a Spider-Man 4
release date now if you haven't been
keeping up with the Spider-Man news no
big deal I'll catch you up real quick
since Sony has released Spider-Man
across the spider-verse obviously
Spider-Man has been a huge topic
recently Spider-Man across the
spider-verse is doing extremely well it
is very well received by the fans and
the critics and is absolutely crushing
it in the box office so of course people
are wondering well hey we want more
Spider-Man is Tom Holland returning a
Spider-Man in Spider-Man 4. and the
great news is Sony has updated us on
this and so has Tom Holland both of
which confirmed they have been having
discussions about Spider-Man 4. the work
has begun and a script was being worked
on however since the wa strike happened
Sony said that they are putting that on
hold Tom Holland confirmed this as well
stating that they were working on it but
when the strike happened they all
decided out of respect to stop so
Spider-Man 4 although it's on pause
right now in its pre-development is
happening but as far as when it's
expected to release Insider Alex P from
the cosmic circus has stated recently
that it is going to be coming out before
Avengers Kang Dynasty now right now
Avengers Kang Dynasty is scheduled for
May 2nd of 2025. so if this report ends
up being true and Alex B does have a
great track record then that means
Spider-Man 4 should be coming out
probably in 2025 a little bit before the
King Dynasty possibly February or March
of 2025. that means they're going to
have to start production and filming in
2024 which is a year from now so if they
started shooting around May or June of
next year that would roughly give them
probably around 9 to 10 months to have
the movie ready which is going to be
pretty tight but unfortunately since the
rider strike is happening right now
Marvel Studios might be delaying things
just a little bit but nothing official
has been said on that yet but right now
it is looking like we are looking at a
2025 release date for Spider-Man 4 the
first half of 2025 if it is indeed
coming before the King Dynasty now it
does seem like Tom Holland has renewed
his contract otherwise he wouldn't
really be having discussions with Marvel
Studios and Sony about what's going to
happen for the next Spider-Man film and
they are in pre-development right now
for it this has been confirmed by Tom
Holland and Sony so looks like the
contract's been renewed and based off of
what we've heard Tom Holland is going to
do three more Spider-Man films solo
Spider-Man films three more team up
projects with two of those being the
next two Avengers films the Kang Dynasty
and Secret Wars then another team up
project that we really don't know
anything about right now an Insider my
time to shine hello has stated that Tom
Holland is going to be the lead of
Avengers Kang Dynasty now this is not to
be confused with the leader of the new
Avengers team but the lead actor and
character of the movie which makes sense
he is an extremely popular character but
in the MCU he is also pretty young to be
the leader of the Avengers team right
now especially when you have people like
Bruce Banner Thor Doctor Strange Hawkeye
one of the ogs basically you understand
Peter Parker is a teenager in the MCU
and everybody else's full-grown adults
for the most part so it makes sense for
him to be the lead but not the leader
however that doesn't mean he's not going
to play a huge role since he's the lead
it's gonna focus on him so expect a
pretty cool Spider-Man story in the King
Dynasty and I'm expecting Secret Wars as
well now as I mentioned we could be
seeing Tom Holland reunite with Toby
Maguire and Andrew Garfield Spider-Man
now of course the first place this is
expected is an Avengers Secret Wars when
universes Collide and our heroes start
seeing variants of themselves from other
universes we are expecting to see Toby
Maguire and Andrew Garfield pop up since
we've already seen them in the MCU this
just makes sense and would kind of be a
pretty big missed opportunity if Marvel
didn't capitalize on it again however
Sony does seem to have their own
Spider-Man plans in the end game for
them their big Avengers in-game level
event could be a huge live-action
spider-verse film where they get a lot
of different Spider-Man variants and
iterations from different universes to
come into one Universe to fight whoever
their big bad of their new spider versus
going to be or multiple villains and one
of those Spider-Man is most likely going
to be Tom Holland Sony definitely isn't
against doing cameos especially if
you've seen across the spider-verse you
know what I'm talking about but Sony is
leading up to a major spider-verse event
and for Tom Holland Spider-Man to not be
in the event would be kind of awkward
yes they're separate universes but Sony
does still own the rights to Spider-Man
and since they have recently made a new
contract with Marvel Studios and Tom
Holland they might have worked it out to
where Tom Holland could cross over into
the other Universe now we know he won't
be a main character in Sony spider-verse
because Marvel Studios doesn't want
people getting confused and mixing up
the universes this is why we never saw
him in venom however of course if you
recall in the Venom 2 post credit scene
we did see Tom Holland kind of in the
Sony Spider-Man universe technically
Venom crossed over into the MCU but it
was still a Sony film that we were
seeing Tom Hall and Spider-Man in and of
course Venom and Eddie Brock went back
and they now know what Tom Holland
Spider-Man looks like and of course
Venom was in the MCU so we've already
had somewhat of a crossover now it was
kind of a tease kind of a jerk move by
Sony to have Tom Hardy's Eddie Brock and
Venom go over to the MCU just to have
that undone by the post-credits scene
for Spider-Man no way home and
essentially tell us hey there is going
to be a Venom in the MCU just not going
to be Tom Hardy that was a slap in the
face however it does confirm that the
two universes can cross over and Sony's
going to do a huge spider-verse event
that's going to have many live-action
Spider-Man and Spider-Man variants
coming together so it would only make
sense for Tom Holland to be a part of
that as well at least for a cameo so I
am expecting that but this is years out
probably after Avengers secret war is
going to take place but the good news is
Tom Holland Spider-Man isn't going
anywhere anytime soon in fact he's got a
lot of Spider-Man left in him yes he's
taking a break for a year and that is a
fantastic thing for him I hope it serves
him well well I hope he stays healthy
but then he's coming back and he's gonna
be Spider-Man so let me know how excited
you are for that and the future of
Spider-Man in the comments down below
don't forget to like the video and
subscribe and leave a comment so you can
enter our giveaway for a chance to win a
PS5 and Xbox series X so Marvel Legends
items or some DC items the winner gets
to pick one item when we pick a winner
at the end of each month we also have a
patreon now where we post exclusive
content we have a website as well where
we post different content and a Discord
server if you want to hang out with
other cool like-minded people and don't
forget to follow us on Instagram and
Twitter as well and as always thank you
all so much for watching wolf wolf
me